[Music]
this necessity however is the unity of
the notion which brings under control
the contradictory substantial being of
the separate moments a unity in which
the inconsistency and arbitrariness of
their action is orderly disposed and the
play of their actions receives its
earnestness and worth in the actions
themselves
the content of the world of pictorial
thought freely unfolds itself in the
middle term on its own account
gathering itself around the
individuality of a hero who however in
his strength and beauty feels his life
is broken and sorrowfully awaits an
early death
for the individuality that is in itself
firmly established an actual is banished
to its extreme and split into its
moments which have not yet found and
united themselves
the one individual moment the abstract
non-actual one is necessity which shares
in the life of the middle term just as
little as does the other the actual
individual the minstrel who keeps
himself outside of it and is lost in his
performance
both extremes must draw nearer to the
content
one of them necessity has to fill itself
with the content the other the language
of the minstrel must participate in it
and the content formerly left to itself
must receive within it the certainty and
the fixed character of the negative
paragraph
732 is shorter than the preceding
paragraph which we saw was quite dense a
lot of stuff going on in there and
similarly there's an awful lot happening
in this paragraph i would say really in
order to understand it
and and this can be said about many
paragraphs i'll go on about this in just
a moment in order to understand this
particular paragraph and what hegel
is doing where the movement is going we
have to look at the previous paragraph
because there's going to be some really
important contrast with what was said
for example about necessity and concepts
in that
but we also need to look ahead to the
next paragraph which begins by saying
this higher language that of tragedy
right so remember that
part of what's going on in this entire
section proceeding
from the last subsection where we found
out that
there's an a new kind of language that
is going to be
more adequate
as a vehicle for religion and it wasn't
specified
in that particular
section or in that paragraph where it
was being brought up
instead it was being contrasted with the
previous forms of language like that of
the frenzied crowd the oracle the hymn
now we're getting
these great
representatives or picture thinking
for you know for stellenda's
forms of we can call them art we often
classify them as literature
and with some of them we teach them not
just in literature but also
as drama so we connect them up with
theater right and so we're in no longer
the living work of art but now solidly
in the spiritual work of art and we
should think about this as bringing in
the abstract and the living and now
rolling them into something more
in this
section the final section of the
second
portion of religion where we're looking
at
religion in the form of art we're now
talking about several main
genres that we we typically associate
with the greeks but which we can find in
many other cultures as well we began
with the epic and now
we are making our transition from the
epic to
drama to
tragedy first and then to comedy and in
the epic the minstrel or the bar the
zenger is going to be
an important as we've seen
mediating term emitter
a middle between extremes hegel likes to
think in terms of middle
joints you know he he often uses the
language of the
syllogism and he's not using it here
generally in the phenomenology in the
ways that we're used to thinking about
syllogisms uh where you've got like you
know uh three different terms and
they're connected together in
propositions
instead um he's going beyond that and
thinking about these as having mediating
functions and you know
this is a bit of a digression
but it's probably worth pointing out
that aristotle himself
known as like
the
uh forger the
producer the classifica in a
classificatory person for syllogisms if
we look at what are called the logical
works
actually has a much broader conception
of syllogism
that we can see coming up in works like
the rhetoric the art of rhetoric right
or
even to some degree in the topics and
being used differently in other words
means
bringing together sun
logoy or or discourses or
conceptions of of things
and bringing them together in a way that
unites them while maintaining
distinction between them
and aristotle talks about human beings
and again this is in the rhetoric
particularly book three
as being
syllogistic meaning being able to
find the middle term and hegel
himself is a prime example
of a thinker who is syllogistic in that
sense not putting things into syllogisms
but rather finding the middle mediating
uniting term that is going to
help us
sort through
what is going on in these developments
and hegel himself is trying to make
sense out of
greek drama and greek epic and in return
you know we could say roman and later
drama and epic as well
he's trying to do so
and think about how this
helps us to understand
the development of religion remember too
that religion
is the next best thing to philosophy
for
for hegel and not just philosophy per se
because there's plenty of philosophies
that fall short of religion what he's
going to call in for example the
lectures on the philosophy of religion
philosophies of the understanding as
opposed to philosophies of reason
so where we're going in this work
ultimately
absolute knowing is philosophy per se
for hegel and religion is like one step
below it and so greek tragedy greek
comedy greek epic also fits in there as
well as you know the other parts of
greek religion
so that's a a lot said i do want to
follow up on just one other thread
before i forget about it that i
mentioned
oftentimes
when we're reading through hegel
and looking at what a particular
paragraph has to say
there is a temptation
to take that paragraph as if it is the
point of view of hegel
that's always a mistake in the
phenomenology right the phenomenology is
a dynamic work that is following out the
development of human consciousness
in
the parts of it that are developing
over time in history through culture
building and and whatever else we want
to translate education cultivation all
those sorts of things
so
you know strictly speaking no one single
paragraph should ever be read upon you
know just by itself in isolation i
understand that in this commentary uh we
are doing something like that because
we've divided up the commentary into
portions and
you know we have to fit them into a
certain
time frame for explanation
but
you should not be reading these
as if they are isolated units
rather you should be
reading
a section at a time right i mean we
could say this about other texts as well
you know if you're reading aristotle's
nick and mccain ethics read the whole
friggin book and i when i say book i
mean basically chapter of the book the
nick of mccain ethics has 10 books so if
you're going to like look at what he has
to say about justice in book five read
the whole thing don't just isolate one
little paragraph out
why not because that's a good way to
make sure that you're not getting the
full meaning of what's going on
obviously some paragraphs are going to
be more intimately connected with each
other than they are to yet other
paragraphs
but
you do want to you know keep that
interconnection
in mind so in this case let's start at
the start
he's referencing at the very beginning
this necessity what necessity the
necessity that was just talked about in
paragraph 731
where what did he tell us about this
necessity well this necessity is an
irrational void as miller has translated
it a mere happening in which they which
they must face as beings without a self
and sorrowfully etc etc and what was the
actual term there it's not irrational
it's actually begriflos right and so we
have a really important contrast going
on here
in paragraph 732.
why because in the first line he says
this necessity is the unity
the ein height
of what
the notion
the grief the concept right
so we've trans we were seeing a
different side of this necessity we
thought ah it's just you know stupid
necessity it can't even be called fate
as i pointed out in the previous one
because it's just dumb you know it's
just the way things are it's like pure
facticity if we want to use later uh
terminology
but no now we're finding out that
this necessity is in fact the unity the
ionite the bringing together the
uh connection
of the
the concept the concept that is hidden
behind the scenes that we can
make sense of this is going to be a very
important point
what does the notion do
brings under control literally places
under itself it it throws under itself
the contradictory
substantial being
of what well we'll get to that in a
moment let's let's focus on that for a
minute again referencing back to the
previous paragraph
where miller was translating you know
contradiction and and i pointed out well
it's really more opposition you know in
this case the term
the terminology being based on and
keegan gazettes right things that are
set in opposition to each other that are
like facing each other and differ from
each other and have some sort of
relation with each other right and we
can think about different oppositions is
black the contradiction of white no it's
really just the opposite of white and in
a certain respect gray could be said to
be not just the mixture of both but the
opposite of both of those two you know
mixed mixture fusion as opposed to
separation right and we could go on and
on and on
with these sort of examples
here we're actually talking about
contradiction
wiederspruch
vader sprechenda right contradictory
from witherspook and i i pointed out
that within hegel we have a rich
terminology that gets used of
contradiction and opposition antithesis
is often how miller will translate these
terms and in between the ant gig and
gazetsta the things that are merely
opposed to each other and the genuine
virus broke the the contradiction we
also have the gegenzotz right which
again miller often translates as
antithesis but sometimes just as
opposition and sometimes has
contradiction right and so hegel here is
saying no we have a real
contradictory
nature
to
substantiality substantially
substantial being now the substantial
being
of what
of the separate moments
the separate moments
have their own substantial beings but
they're also a substantial being
together and then he says a unity
the necessity brings a unity
the unity of the notion in which the
inconsistency
and arbitrariness of their action
is orderly disposed literally ordinate
now
we saw this was a term
you know the substantive
form of uh ordnan right that was used
earlier and was
being said this is not an ordinance
right now we actually do have an ordinal
a putting things into their proper
places
a providing
context hierarchy
ordering uh connection with each other
valorization we could say
order orderly disposes the inconsistency
right and there's this inconsistent
right
and the arbitrariness zoo feligit
um now that's interesting
because
again we we might have seen here
especially when we're talking about
action
tet in this case or dot rather um indeed
we might have expected to see a
different kind of arbitrariness being
talked about veal curly kite right
something being uh up to the vilker the
arbitrary will of a person instead this
is more like contingency
which would be like almost a
you know a literal translation of it uh
felig right uh consist uh you know
contingency comes from cadre right
so the the way things just happen to
turn out
is being given
an orderly disposition
some sort of structure to it
that
that provides
intelligibility
that says
well this isn't just one damn thing
after another to summarize i forget
whose
view of history that was we could also
say that about
novels or plays or
other sorts of things one damn thing
after another that's a great way of
understanding zouphelickite
so he says
[Music]
there we go the the play of their
actions receives its earnestness and
worth and here miller is translating
very very close to the german
earnestness um uh
ernst right um
and worth
that
uh could be translated as value as well
the play of actions the spiel
right is being given
uh earnestness and worth earnestness
being get being given a kind of honesty
a kind of straightforwardness a kind of
here's what you get and being assigned a
value is another way of putting it and
it receives it in the actions
themselves
it's you know in
in the actions themselves is a little
bit of a periphrastic
translation now notice that we've got a
a connection here right we've got
inconsistency and arbitrariness in the
single action the deed
and we have um the play the spiel
of actions han lungen
the play of um
the structure of actions intentional
actions right no longer just arbitrary
and these are being provided with this
by that necessity so that necessity is
doing some work here some important work
we go on the content
of the world of pictorial thought okay
so pictorial thought yet another
translation on miller's part miller
almost never uses the word that so many
other people do use for foreign
representation right he's got all sorts
of other things instead picture language
pictorial thought but you get what we're
talking about here there's some sort of
connection to images that are universal
but not yet universal enough not like
the concept
and can be
placed at a sort of distance from
ourselves we can contemplate them we can
uh
name them and and and talk about them so
the content of the world
notice again we're talking about a world
being created here of pictorial thought
freely
unfolds itself in the middle term on its
own account the middle term the mitta
in the syllogism and the connection
between
things
gathering itself he says round so here's
the question okay what is the middle
point
in the past
it was supposed to be the
minstrel right the person who
composes or at least recites
the epic
homer
his uh followers and continuers
but it's that's not the middle term in
this case
the middle term
might also be
the
person who is
in charge
right in this case it's not quite that
although there's nothing to prevent a
hero from being in charge
some heroes there's a bit of a
digression some heroes in ancient greece
probably shouldn't be in charge
agamemnon achilles neither one of them
are
really great leaders when it comes down
to it right who would have been better
to be put in charge you know mentor
odysseus
um
[Music]
odysseus is in charge of his men in the
odyssey
right um
who else
uh jason
not a very good leader at all
anyway we we've got the middle term and
what is the middle term in this case
he says um the content gathers itself
around the individuality of a hero we're
going to talk about the condition of
this hero as it's depicted here in just
a moment but notice the individuality
individuality
of a hero and held right
somebody who is
representative of what's
best or at least part of what's best in
that culture what's admired
able to do things
what is at the extreme
here's where it gets very very
interesting and we have to engage in a
little bit of speculation
the individuality that is in itself
firmly established in actual is banished
to its extreme
and split into its moments which have
not yet found and united itself right
individuality but not individualite
einstein
so hegel is making a distinction here
between what miller is translating as
individuality in both cases
individualite something that is also
representative that stands in the middle
and the thing that's placed over to the
extreme
einstein
he says firmly established
in zeke festa it it it stays in its own
condition
right
actual via click now that's really
interesting and and those two things are
connected together
actuality standing firm in its own
condition
as opposed to the
literary
imaginative
depicted
hero
a little bit earlier in the morality
section you know hegel has a lot of
famous quips uh nobody's a hero to his
own valet
right
was was one of them that's brought up in
the morality section he's taking that
from somebody else as well but
when we see the reality of the hero the
veer clique kite what they are in
themselves as they're sitting at their
table sipping coffee
in their pajamas
you know not showered
not getting anything done pissing away
the day you know we we that's less
heroic isn't it
and you know that's different than
achilles sulking in his tent because
he's angry with agamemnon who he chose
not to kill right that that's the
depicted hero
what was achilles really like um should
we go to you know watching movies no
because those are for stellangen too
right um if brad pitt is achilles at
troy that's just a depiction
right the real stinking
you know uh screwing things up achilles
is a
individuality in einstein who is actual
and we could go on and on and on with
all this sort of stuff what was the real
odysseus like assuming that odysseus
actually
existed did it really take him 20 years
to get home did he single-handedly or
with the aid of his son dispatch all
those suitors
well you know it's a great story
but the actuality
might be a little less
interesting or i mean for those of us
who are into history
um we do find this sort of stuff very
interesting think about king arthur if
we want to use a prime example of this
or any of his knights
you know
and think about the way that they they
get depicted right
so here's there's a bit of a tangent but
um think about the you know heraldry and
you know
you everything is so so up and you know
above board and stuff like that and
arthur is this kind of innocent guy
who's forced into stuff i mean what we
know if about if there really was a king
arthur he was probably some romanized
britain who was fighting against
anglo-saxon invaders things were not as
black and white as it seemed to be and
maybe some of the knights existed like
the knights that are depicted now think
about the old time movies where
everybody's very chivalrous and then
think about darker
you know reworks what do we call them
gritty reboots are gritty reboots
getting us to the
real individuality no they're another
kind of uh
representation aren't they
because they're all gritty reboots in
the same damn way as we've realized
gritty reboots are actually kind of
boring these days because it's been done
to death hasn't it all right back to
hegel uh after that that little
digression so
this individuality um is he says the one
individual moment the abstract
non-actual one so now what's at the
other extreme
individuality
hero
what's on the other side is it god
or the gods
as it was before
is it necessity the necessity that's up
here already
is it the minstrel
himself
well hegel says this
the one individual moment the abstract
non-actual one
is necessity
which shares in the life of the middle
term just as little just as little it's
not there where the hero the depiction
of the hero is
a living depiction
necessity is where on one side
as the necessity of the situation
perhaps but also the overarching
necessity
and then who else do we have here
as the actual individual
the minstrel
who keeps himself outside of it and is
lost in his
performance so the
minstrel is not exactly the same as any
old individuality einstein height that
is actual right
the minstrel is lost in the
picturing the for stellang for stellen
rather
of the
action of all these other things the
play of actions the contradictory
substantiality
let's go back to the hero because
we skipped over that a little bit so
what's distinctive about this hero
the hero who
however in his strength and beauty
uh
feels
his life is broken and sorrowfully
awaits an early death
is that very heroic
well you know the hero does have
strength this the hero does have
beauty and not beauty as in like you
know achilles was such a good looking
guy
but beauty as in
shen height
or the greek cologne nobility fineness
admirability honor
right all of those sorts of
things odysseus might be kind of a
crafty bastard but he's still odysseus
he's still a cool guy right um ajax may
be kind of you know not the brightest
guy and really stubborn and prone to
bloodlust but
he's a tower among men on the fields of
troy right so we can go on and on and
every one of the greek heroes
whether in epic
or in
tragedy
meets some sort of bad end with the
exception of
odysseus
right
so
anyway going back to this the minstrel
keeps himself outside of it lost in his
performance says both extremes must draw
nearer to the content
and now this is interesting how are they
doing that
one of them necessity has to fill itself
with the content why because necessity
is empty
the the only
necessities of void as we saw alera in
the last paragraph
so that's going back to the previous
paragraph how does necessity
go from being degree flows
concept-less to being the unity of the
notion or concept through drawing near
to the
content
the other he says
the language of the minstrel notice he
doesn't just say the minstrel
the language of the minstrel the use of
that language
must participate in it in the content
and the content formerly left to itself
must receive within it the certainty
this height
and the fixed character
bestimong the negative we saw the
negative being talked about in the
previous paragraph right um the
what do we have here the the uh ultim
the pure power of the negative as the
ultimate power over it and against which
it can do nothing right uh the gods and
the the mortals both
and here uh we're talking about the
certainty and fixed character
of the negative how does it get fixed
character
in the forest shelling
in the picturing in
the actions
so we have a lot going on here and where
are we going well let's look at the
next sentence of the previous paragraph
this higher language that of tragedy the
higher language who just had language
the minstrel
the minstrel is now going to become the
tragedy writer
you